مشاهدينا اذا العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه استؤنفت في قطاع غزه
وتتحدث المصادر الاسرائيليه عن عمليات
عسكريه ستجري بالتوازي ما بين الشمال شمال
قطاع غزه وجنوب قطاع غزه اضافه الى مدينه
غزه نبدا طبعا نرحب باللواء فيز دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي معنا هنا في
الاستوديو ولكن البدايه مع سلام خضر
الزميله سلام تطلعنا عبر الخريطه
التفاعليه على ابرز نقاط العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه اليوم بعد استئناف
هذه العمليات حسن منذ السابعه صباحا عندما
انتهت او انتهى الوقت المفترض للهدنه
قالت اسرائيل انها بدات عمليه او استانفت
العمليه العسكريه على قطاع غزه طبعا القصف
والغارات امتدت على كامل مساحات القطاع من
شمال القطاع الى جنوبه لكن اللافت اليوم
هو ما قالت اسرائيل انها
بداته بشكل مركز وهو استهداف مناطق الجنوب
خان يونس بالتحديد اليوم تعرضت لغارات
اسرائيليه عنيفه جدا وقال شهود عيان ان
اسرائيل نفذت ما يمكن تسميتها بالاحزمه
الناريه وهي الضربات المكثفه على منطقه
واحده تتركز فيها الغارات والقصف المدفعي
الطائرات الاسرائيليه ايضا القت بمناشي
قالت او دعت فيها سكان بعض مناطق خانيونس
للنزوح باتجاه مدينه رفح علما ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي عندما بدا الحرب على قطاع غزه
كان قد طلب من سكان شمال القطاع التوجه
الى جنوب القطاع على اساس انه منطقه امنه
الان الجنوب هو المستهدف الى حد بعيد ليس
خانيونس فقط ايضا هناك استهدافات وشهداء
في مدينه رفح ننتقل ايضا الى قلب القطاع
الى مدينه غزه تتعرض ايضا لغارات
اسرائيليه بعض مناطق المدينه تتعرض لغارات
اسرائيليه مقابل اشتباكات قالت كتائب
القسام انها تشتبك في اكثر من نقطه بمحيط
عند في مدينه غزه عند عده محاور في مدينه
غزه منها اشتباكات قريبه من حي الشيخ
رضوان واشت اكات اخرى الى جنوب غرب مدينه
غزه وتصف كتائب عز الدين القسام هذه
الاشتباكات مع الجيش الاسرائيلي بانها
ضاريه وتقول انها ايضا تستهدف اليات
عسكريه ودبابات
اسرائيليه ايضا تعرض للقصف عده مناطق منها
الشجاعيه وجباليا و بعض المناطق المحاذيه
لها واسقطت عده شهداء هذه الغارات صباحا
كانت مكثفه جدا في هذه المناطق وادت الى
سقوط عدد كبير من الاصابات
والشهداء طبعا بموازاه القصف الذي تتعرض
له قطاع غزه المقاومه وكتائب القسام شنت
عده هجمات صاروخيه قالت انها استهدفت
كيسوفيم واستهدفت ايضا رعيم
واستهدفت زيكيم وايضا وصلت صواريخ
المقاومه اذا صواريخ للمقاومه على عده
مناطق وصلت الى
عسقلان وهذه هي التطورات الميدانيه حتى
الان حسن لتفسير هذه الامور نعود لك و و
من حيث انتهيت سابدا مع اللواء فيز
الدويري اذا استؤنفت العمليات العسكريه
تحديدا الان في الشمال وايضا استؤنف قصف
المقاومه بالصواريخ وايضا الاشتباكات في
اكثر من منطقه في شمال قطاع غزه مع قوات
الاحتلال يعني اولا لابد من العوده الى
التصريح الذي صدر عن الناطق العسكري
والجهات العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال عندما
تحدث عن عمليه التوازي او التزامن بمعنى
اخر التوجه هو اي لمهاجمه القطاع كذلك
كانما تحدثت قبل قليل الزميله وقالت
المنشورات طالبت سكان خان يونس بالتوجه
الىى رفح في البدايه كان المطالبه بتوجه
سكان شمال القطاع الى جنوب بالقطاع الان
اين هو جنوب القطاع المركز الرئيسي كان
خان يونس الان يطالب سكان خان يونس
بالذهاب الى رفح هل نحن الان بصدد انتظار
عده ايام حتى يكون الخطاب الموجه
للمتواجدين في
الرفحاء غزه هل نعود الى الحلقه الاولى
والدائره الاولى الحديث عن اخلاء غزه هل
نعود الى الحديث عن ضروره كما قال وزير
الاثار ضرب غزه بالقنبله الذريه هل على ما
قاله بن كفير في هذا اليوم بانه يجب
استعاده السيطره عليها بالمطلق ويجب ان
تكون تحت السيطره النهائيه واعاده
الاستيطان هذا هو الوجه الحقيقي للعمليات
العسكريه وبالتالي علينا الذهاب باتجاه
السيناريو العسوى الذي يسعى من خلاله
لتحقيقه لكن اعتقد ان الفشل سيكون من
نصيبه هوان سيصعد في العمليات العسكريه
ويتابع المعارك ال في منطقه الشمال وبدا
هذا الامر من من اكثر من اتجاه بدا من
اتجاه الشمالي الشمال الغربي والجنوب
الغربي اي من مناطق توام وابراج الكرامه
من مناطق بيت لاهيه بيت حنون وحتى من
الشمال الغربي من منطقه تل الهواء هذا
الجزء الاول وقد يكون في الساعات القادمه
تشديد الاشتباكات والدفع
باتجاه الشجاعيه والتفاح هذا فيما يتعلق
بالجزء الشمالي اما اذا ذهبنا بالجزء
الجنوبي التركيز على على خان يونس الان
خان يونس هناك مساحتها تقريبا تعادل مساحه
القطاع الشمالي فان عندما اتحدث عن محافظه
خان يونس مساحتها التقريبيه تعادل مساحه
القاطع الشمالي ولكن حجم المدينه اصغر من
حجم غزه اذا هناك مسافات بينيه وهناك
بلدات وقرى منتشره انا اتصور ان السيناريو
الاسو الذي يفكر فيه جيش الاحتلال هو
سيدفع بقوه مزدوجه قوه تدخل من شمال خان
يونس لفصلها عن للح وقوه من جنوب خان يونس
لفصل عن رفح ويحاول الوصول الى شارع
الرشيد حتى يحقق الفصل الكامل فوق الارض
وليس تحت الارض كما جرى في المنطقه
الشماليه لا اتصور انه سيبدا بمهاجمه
مدينه خان يونس قد يسيطر على البلدات
والقرى المحيطه وكنت قد بدات معك بسؤال عن
ردود المقاومه وكتائب القسام تقول انها
قصفت قاعده رعيم وان تيفوت وسديد برشقات
صاروخيه ايضا كان هناك اشتباكات حصلت مع
قوات الاحتلال هذا المشهد الذي عاد ليتكرر
من جديد يطرح السؤال هل سيكون من السهل
على قوات
الاحتلال
زياده مناطق توغلها ورقع تها الان هذا
يعتمد على حجم القوه التي حشدها تحدثنا
وقلنا انه المجموع الكلي لديه 650 الف
لانه دعى 300 ال من الاحتياط
و لديه قوه فاعله 150 الف فهو القوه التي
وظفها تقريبا 450 من 650 لن يدعو احتياط
جديد لانه بدا يسرح جزء من الاحتياط بسبب
الوضع الاقتصادي نتحدث عن 450,000 هذه يجب
يجب في الظروف العاديه توزع على ثلاث
جبهات واحتياط رئيسي الجبهه الشماليه الان
الجبهه الشماليه هناك صافرات انذار في
الشمال هذه اشاره ان هذه الجبهه قد تشتعل
وان كان اشتعال منم ضبطا انها تشارك في
المعركه وليس وحده ساحات لكن ستجبر على
ابقاء جزء من قوات في تلك المنطقه الان
عذرا لانه نحن على راس الساعه لواء فاز
دويري طبعا سنعود اليك في شرح مفصل في
محطات اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك وعوده مشاهدينا
الى اي التغطيه الميدانيه